انا مريضه كانسر في التدي انا ام بعيل تسع
اطفال انا مريضه فقر دم لاسينيا حسي عيني
اناما تطلع الشمس ماقدر عيني صير الحمر زي
الدم انا اسمي محمد وعمري 12 سنه وانا معي
فجور دم علاجنا مرميين على
الراصي العلاج حقه يمكن 6 مليون 5 مليون
ناكلها والله نفسنا بالحاجه ما احنا
قادرين ناكلها انا لازم اعمل عمليه اشيل
التدي اليمين بس الوقت بيقوللك طوارئ خليك
على المسكنات وخليك على العلاجات عمال ما
تحل الدنيا طب انا لو متت فجاه من قلت
العلاج انا وين يروحوا اودي هدول وين
يروحوا عندك علاجك لا والله حقه 5 مليون
ما احنا قادرين نجيبه عمرنا ما مسكنا
المليون بدين عالجوني يا عم ما
بقدرش
كان له علاج قبل الحرد كانوا ياتوننا على
الضفه اتعالج له بس لما قت الحرض خلص يعني
وين نروح هذا احنا مزلين في
الشارع لا في دول الناس المسنه لا في
علاجات للاطفال حتى حليب الاطفال صعب
نلاقيه عن هنا سبع حالات وفاه صارت سبع
حالات وفاه نصل
نصل المستشفى جس هامده مافيش هنا رعايه
صحيه كام بالمره معدومه في
المخيم وين نروح ايش نعمل يا عمي بدهم
ايانا بموت الشعب والله من قلت الاكل ضعف
وصار معي حصور دم ومش عارف
ايه